el silencio de la madrugada en San
Marcos de atexquilapan en el Oriente
mexicano era solo interrumpido por los
pasos de unas 100 personas se dirigían
al pie de la patrona espiritual de
México para recibir los cuerpos de tres
jóvenes migrantes hallados sin vida
dentro de un camión en el estado de
Texas el pasado mes de junio
[Música]
los gritos de dolor retumbaron en la
noche Giovanni y Misael de 16 años y
Yahir de 19 dos hermanos y un primo que
no podrán cumplir sus sueños como las
cosas están subiendo de precio pues las
cosas suben pero el trabajo no le suben
Pues por eso ellos tuvieron que salir a
buscar una mejor vida como Yolanda otros
familiares ya recibieron a sus seres
queridos perfecto
recordar las aspiraciones de los
difuntos es una manera de rendir el
atributo también para recordar los
peligros que afrontan al cruzar de
manera ilegal la frontera Nosotros hemos
difundido en redes sociales una campaña
constante de que no se arriesguen
sabemos que la migración es un derecho
universal pero hay que hacerlo de manera
informada y y y y
respetando los derechos humanos de cada
persona los primeros 16 cuerpos llegaron
Desde el miércoles en aviones militares
la cancillería mexicana informó otro
para repatriar los cadáveres restantes
según reporte este forenses 26 mexicanos
murieron en el remolque abandonado en
Texas de los cuales 25 serán repatriados
mientras el dolor inundaba los hogares
mexicanos otro grupo intentaba cruzar el
río fronterizo entre México y Estados
Unidos en busca de un futuro mejor al
precio necesario el hallazgo de 53
cuerpos sin vida en la parte trasera de
un camión fue el evento más trágico en
la historia reciente de la migración
rumbo Norte